people have been dancing since the dawn
of time it's one of the oldest art forms
known to man but while dancing can often
lighten the mood sometimes it can be
downright horrific while a good guy
dance routine can make audiences smile
a bad guy break down is guaranteed to
send chills through the movie theater
from psychopathic thugs with a love of
swing tunes to disturb supervillains
with a fondness for hip hop these are
the creepiest movie dances of all time
candy colored clown almost everything
David Lynch has done feels like a dream
blue velvet is certainly no exception
while it's a little more grounded in
reality than some of his other films the
movie has plenty of eerie moments and
when it comes to pure surreal spookiness
it doesn't get any creepier than the in
dreams dance sequence the otherworldly
floor show gets started when college
student Jeffrey Beaumont is abducted by
a savage gangster named Frank booth soon
Jeffrey Frank and their criminal
companions wind up in the world's
weirdest bordello run by a guy named bin
at Frank's request bin performs Roy
Orbison's in dreams and eerie song about
a candy colored clown the entire
sequence is more of a nightmare than a
dream and it's one dance that you won't
forget for a long time the Goblin ball
directed by Jim Henson labyrinth is a
beloved coming-of-age fantasy but really
it's about a full-grown dude stalking an
underage girl okay it's not really about
that but Jennifer Connelly Beane 15 does
make the film feel kind of freaky as
David Bowie was 23 years her senior and
things get extra weird during the masked
ball sequence after eating an enchanted
peach that puts her to sleep
teenage sarah winds up in a dreamlike
party that has some serious Eyes Wide
Shut vibes everyone is wearing creepy
monster masks and the whole thing feels
a little too sinister it gets even
weirder when jerath the Goblin King
makes his move seducing the girl with
his 80s hair waltzing prowess and tight
pants fortunately when Sarah realizes
it's all a distraction to stop her from
saving her brother she snaps out of her
spell and makes a grand exit literally
crashing the party Buffalo Bill boogie
the morbid world of Thomas Harris is
populated with all sorts of serial
killers but none of these psychos have
moves like Jame Gumb aka Buffalo Bill in
the Silence of the Lambs
during his infamous dance scene Buffalo
Bill is down in his basement and totally
oblivious to the screaming woman he's
dewayne is dungeon listening to goodbye
horses bill sachets around the room
wearing nothing more than a robe
stockings and a woman's scalp in an
interview with Rolling Stone Levine said
he'd originally prepared a stripper
routine but ended up going with more of
a David Bowie glam vibe honestly it
would have been creepy either way stuck
in the middle mr. blonde is many things
he's a thief an ex-con a murderer and a
sadist and to top it all off the man
fancies himself something of a performer
the nastiest thug in Reservoir Dogs
blonde gets way too much pleasure
torturing a poor police officer it's a
horrific scene even if the worst part
does happen off screen but what makes it
worse is how blonde is strutting around
the warehouse grooving to stealers wheel
and taking a sweet time before getting
busy his twisted little dance draws out
the tension as long as possible before
the bloodshed begins as far as movie
dances go this is easily one of the most
painful to watch
Black Swan take over sometimes becoming
a great artist means working for untold
hours until you one day achieve
perfection and sometimes it means you're
haunted by doppelgangers and you start
morphing into a bird at least that's
what happens to Nina Sayers in Black
Swan a naive ballerina struggling to
keep the lead role in Swan Lake
Nina falls deeper and deeper into
madness over the course of the film when
she finally gives in to the darkness she
delivers the performance of her life
and while this creepy dance eventually
climaxes with disastrous results Natalie
Portman danced away from it all with an
Oscar for Best Actress dance ex machina
everything about ex machina is
unsettling from the isolated landscape
to Alicia vikander chilling performance
it's an unbearably tense movie and it
never lets up even when the sense of
dread gives way to one of the greatest
damn scenes in cinema history the sci-fi
disco gets started after a computer
programmer named Caleb is chosen by
billionaire inventor Nathan to help test
whether robot Ava can pass for human
however things start getting creepy very
quickly and soon Caleb suspects Nathan's
relationship with his robot Ava might be
a tad unhealthy but when Caleb goes to
confront Nathan about his obsessive
behavior the tech genius ignores Caleb's
questions and starts to boogie beside
his mistress Kyoko however you would not
be wasting your time if you were dancing
with her their choreography is a little
too perfect and this out of nowhere
number will give you the creeps even
before you find out the secret to their
musical success hedwig busts a move
anya taylor joy is fantastic and split
but it's James McAvoy who's constantly
stealing the show McAvoy plays Kevin
Windell crumb a man with 23 different
personalities including a nine-year-old
boy named Hedwig
but Hedwig isn't pure evil he's just a
scared confused kid who wants to show
Casey his CD player sensing an
opportunity to escape Kevin's dungeon
Casey takes Hedwig up on his offer but
winds up witnessing one of the scariest
moments in the movie on the one hand
watching McAvoy dance with such
enthusiasm is pretty entertaining at the
same time Hedwig's dance is downright
disturbing we're watching a truly sick
man here a guy grooving to hip hop music
while he's got several girls locked away
in his own private prison the look on
Anya Taylor joys face really sums it up
the perfect mix of horror and
bewilderment